he was a man who was impossible to
ignore the flamboyant character with a
cigar and a $50,000 pinkie ring although
he weighed over 250 pounds he could when
the occasion demanded it move with
lethal speed and force his jolly smile
contrasted with the two scars that
streaked across his left cheek then
there was his clothing his wardrobe was
nothing short of outrageous custom
tailored purple suits pearl gray fedoras
and diamond encrusted stick pens
he loved attention wanting people to
adore him even as he ruthlessly
dispatched those who had no use for his
name was Al Capone and he has become the
symbol of American greed and corruption
in the 1920s and 30s when his eyes On
January the 25th 1947 the New York Times
called him a monstrous symbol of a
disease which was eating into the
conscious of America but the paper went
on to say poem was incredible the
creation of an evil dream yes almost
everything that the public thought they
knew about him man's the most of us
think we know today is false the
products of decades of glorification and
myth making and in today's bio graphics
video we're gonna peel back the layers
to discover the real Al Capone
[Music]
Gabrielle and Teresa Capone made the big
move from Sicily to New York in 1894
they ended up in a four room flat on
Park Avenue adjacent to the Brooklyn
Navy Yard the couple had two sons in tow
the youngest who was just a few months
old the third boy followed shortly after
their arrival a barber by trade
gabrielle was looking for a new life in
america what he found was a city in
which immigrants were viewed as lower
citizens Italians especially were
vilified by Americans who blamed the
spiraling crime rate that in New York
was experiencing on them yet the
Capone's they were a hard-working family
they were law-abiding and trying to fit
in to their new society when their
fourth son Alphonse was born in 1899 the
family had settled into a decent but
hard existence life around the Brooklyn
Naval Yard
it was pretty rough-and-tumble and by
the age of 10 young Al Capone had begun
to exhibit the toughness and brashness
that he carried into his adult life from
the start al emerged as a natural leader
at the age of 14 he formed the Navy
Street gang in order to protect Italian
women from harassment from their Irish
neighbors by now he had been expelled
from school for punching a female
teacher in the face but you know what he
said well she ended him first just prior
to World War one the Capone's they moved
out of the Italian ghetto Gabrielle's
head down and get on with it attitude
was paying off and al found himself in
an upwardly mobile middle-class
community still further up the hill vote
was worthy really well-off people lived
this area
it was strictly off-limits for the likes
of the Capone's the teenage owl looked
upon this area in envious eyes this was
where the Rockefeller snooped and feisty
teens saw no reason why he couldn't live
the Rockefeller way he just had to find
a means
[Music]
by the age of 19 al had become a local
tough he knew how to use a gun and a
knife he was a big brutish brawler who
could knock a man to the ground with a
single punch it also found himself a
family on December 30th 1918 he married
maid Coughlin who was 2 years older than
him three weeks previously may have
given birth to their son Albert family
life in encourage Capone to get on the
straight and narrow intent on turning to
a respectful life worthy of his wife and
Charles he moved the family out of the
neighborhood and away from the bad
influences they shifted to Baltimore and
Al took a job as a bookie but ironically
this straight job would come in handy
down the track when he was juggling
millions of dollars and from bootleg
liquor now that could have been the end
of the story for Alphonse in major pain
they could have settled into an
uneventful life of respectability in
Baltimore maybe even work their way up
the social ladder to gain some community
status but well as we well know that
wasn't to be
[Music]
with the sudden death of his father of a
heart attack
Al's flirtation with respectability
while it was over he returned for the
funeral and soon found that the family
were now looking to him for guidance as
well as financial support that would
require more money than he was earning
as a bookkeeper in Baltimore meanwhile
the local gang Vord al had pulled away
from an outgrowth of the manhattan-based
five points gang they were to cross
ropes six months earlier and that he a
bigwig in Chicago named Big Jim Colosimo
had been struck dead the leader of the
gang that Capone had pulled away from
Johnny Torrio was intent on stepping
into the vacuum created by big Jim's
demise he invited Capone to join him as
his right-hand man Torrio had been
grooming component for the last couple
of years had given him a job as a
collector to ensure extortion payments
were made al he soon graduated to become
the main bouncer and bartender at the
Harvard Inn on Coney Island now it was
one night of this establishment that al
told a female patron that she had a nice
rear end the girl's brother well she
doesn't take so kindly to the remark and
in an instant hit carved up Capone's
face with a bottle opener for the rest
of his life al would carry dual stripes
down his chink giving rise to the name
Scarface
[Music]
now while they've been in Baltimore
rumors had circulated that our had been
involved in a couple of murders one
prostitute who was suspected of
withholding pimp money and the other was
a friend who'd reneged on a gambling
debt
all of this was bringing unwanted police
attention to the gang and shortly after
his father's funeral Capone was called
to a meeting with Lucky Luciano a key
member of the gang so what's going on
now it's reported to have asked
nervously I'll tell you what's going on
Luciano replied you gonna get the hell
out of town don't bother to pack Luciano
he then handed al an envelope which
contained two thousand dollars which is
about $25,000 in today's money and
directed him to go straight to Grand
Central Station and head for Chicago al
arrived in Chicago in 1921 ready willing
and eager to learn the ropes he left his
wife of a behind in Brooklyn with
instructions to follow once it
established their new life the challenge
now for Johnny Torrio the leader of the
gang was to get Al Capone to stop using
his fists and start using his brains in
order to succeed in the rackets he put
Capone in the position of head bouncer
and bartender at the four deuces a
four-story building which served as
Torrio's general officers which also
housed a saloon at Cafe the top floor of
this establishment well that was a
brothel and Al apparently spent quite a
lot of time on that floor where he
wasn't exactly working indeed his sexual
proclivities resulted in a lifelong
battle with syphilis
[Music]
this it was no place for the weak of
heart
countless unsolved murders took place
there with al playing a leading hand in
dispatching those who Torrio wanted
eliminated in fact al did so well within
the year but he was made a partner
sharing envy $100,000 annual profits now
Torrio tore Capone how to portray an air
of respectability even as he delved
deeper and deeper into the underworld as
a cover Al opened a secondhand furniture
store next door
he carried business cards announcing his
occupation as furniture dealer as
Chicago authorities began to crack down
on organized crime Torrio spread his
business interests into the suburbs in
the suburbs local police and politicians
well they could be controlled more
easily in fact it was Torrio's expansion
beyond Chicago that was the key to the
development of the empire that Capone
would eventually inherit by the time
Capone arrived in the Windy City Sario
had already set up Vice gambling and
prostitution operations in the nearby
town of Berner then with the election of
crime busting Chicago Mayor William
evine in October of 1923 the entire base
of the operation was moved to the
western suburb of Cicero
[Music]
[Applause]
the plant was to make Cicero a wide-open
town where the gang could peddle booze
and accommodate gamblers at will to do
so Torrio he reached an agreement with
the authorities to shut down his
brothels in Cicero so long as he had
free rein on the other two arms of his
business by cutting the police and
politicians in on the profits Johnny
soon developed the operation he wanted
within six months of moving in the
outfit owned the town of Cicero lock
stock and barrel by January of 1924
Torrio felt so confident in his position
that he embarked on a trip back to the
old country where he planned to set his
mother up in a fine home in Venice in
his absence Mao would be in charge Alice
first challenge was to make sure that
the officials who had his back well that
they stayed in office the local
elections were to be held April and
Capone was prepared to go to any lengths
to keep the incumbents in office well
what's the way Al Capone would do this
well that would be by bringing some
extra muscle he brought his two older
brothers Ralph and Frank over from New
York
the brothers thought nothing of
destroying ballots and replacing them
with votes for their own candidates
everyone kind of just went along with
whatever the Capone's did the police
sheriff even the state's attorney they
all went along with this apparently
deciding that it was futile to trying to
pose them on the day of the election in
Cicero Torrio Capone gangsters used guns
and fists to intimidate voters escorting
them to the ballot box and watching them
drop their votes for the incumbent mayor
directly into the box honest poll
Watchers and election officials were
held captive until after the ballot
closed honest citizens well obviously
they were outraged of this some of them
even called upon Chicago Judge Edmonds
DJ rocky to do something about the
Cicero gang
Jarecki deputized 70 Chicago cops who
went into Cicero in plain clothes and
unmarked black sedans
they seemed spotted Frank Capone on the
street gunning him down and riddling his
body with bullets
when our heard about his brother's
slaying all of the sophistication that
Torrio had imbued him over the last year
was ripped away his savage nature was
Unleashed as he vowed to take revenge it
took all of Torrio's persuasive skill to
keep him in check but Torrio he was not
able to keep Capone out of a spotlight
staying in the backgrounds having owls
Minds
cost the life of his brother Torrio he
continued to preach non-violence only
resorting to brute force when all else
fails but the name of Al Capone
well that was synonymous with violence
this is something that's pretty well
illustrated in contemporary culture
we've got a clip here thanks to
Boardwalk Empire pretty nicely sums up
how we see Al Capone
now try as he might to follow his
leaders advice Capone was plagued by
mayhem and a temper that he found
difficult to control
Al's base nature was combative rather
than diplomatic and it resulted in an
awful lot of bloodshed in the years that
were to come
Al's pent-up emotions over the death of
his brother Frank were given expression
on the evening of May the 8th 1924 his
partner in a prostitution ring a Jacke
music had been roughed up by an Irish
thug named Joe Howard fought with using
him alone Capone
immediately tracked down Howard in a bar
and demanded to know what happens Howard
took one look at Capone called in a Dago
pimp and then told him to get lost
at this point Capone pulled out his
pistol and shot Howard in the face and
he did this in front of dozens of
witnesses
[Music]
the more it never convicted out for this
brazen murder but the press they
certainly did the original story
identified him as Al Brown but when it
was picked up by other papers it was
corrected to Alphonse Capone this was
really the beginning of his public
persona and when he became famous for it
less than a year later in January of
9025 Johnny Torrio was ambushed by rival
gang members he came within an inch of
losing his life surviving only to have a
nine-month prison term slapped on him
for operating an illegal brewery while
inside he decided that it had enough of
the Chicago madness by the end of that
year had completely handed the reins
over to Capone and he disappeared Capone
he inherited a gold mine from Johnny
Torrio that was fueled by a highly
organized operation that operated
largely behind the scenes in fact the
duplicity was so complete that 99% of
the citizens of Cicero never even saw a
gangster rather than AA be used the
government to control the area with
non-compliant merchants being plagued
with higher taxes and loss of parking in
front of their stores
well they quickly got the message and
they got into lying
[Music]
[Applause]
now Capone set his sights on the north
side of Chicago to make some headway he
first had to subjugate the deadliest
gang Chicago had ever known the genes--
they operated in the open even having
police protection the genes-- also had
been major suppliers of alcohol to the
Torrio Capone outfit and Capone had even
supported them in their battles with
other gangs but after crushing the rival
O'Banion gang the Jenners decided to
take over the Capone Empire it would
prove to be their undoing the genna's
selected a couple of Sicilians to
assassinate Capone however recognizing
Capone's power and fearful that such an
attempt would lead to their own demise
the Sicilian duo informed Capone of the
Jenners intentions al convinced them to
turn on the Genesis and in short order
they had killed three of the Genna
brothers the remaining three brothers
while they fled to Sicily with the
genna's while they were out of the way
the piont now had to deal with the
survivors of the O'Banion gang who had
raided Capone's headquarters a number of
times on one particular occasion made
used 8 touring cars they first shot
blanks to lure people outside and then
followed with live ammunition hoping to
kill Capone on the spot the ruse well it
didn't work though over 1,000 rounds
were fired miraculously no one was
killed al was convinced that the brains
behind this attempted hit was Hymie
Weiss leader of the O'Banion gang and he
immediately ordered the death of this
man but hitmen set themselves up across
from Weiss's flower shop and waited and
waited and waited after a week they
finally spotted Weiss walking towards
his shop they killed him and three of
his bodyguards successfully stepping
into the vacuum created by the killing
of Hymie Weiss with bugs moorim who was
as eager to get rid of Capone as Weiss
had been moran had plenty of guts but
little common sense he publicly
denounced Capone especially for peddling
bad
and bad alcohol constantly on the attack
Moran's troops launched a number of
forays against Capone's businesses by
february of 1929 Capone had had enough
he ordered a massive hit on Capone to
take place on some Valentine's Day the
killers disguised as policemen entered
Moran's warehouse and caught the seven
victims off-guard facing them towards
the wall as if they were gonna frisk
them they then moved them down with
machine-gun fire
Moran was not among them but this attack
but it was enough to scare him off
having eliminated all opposition on the
north side of Chicago Capone now focused
on the south after a number of killings
his rivals
well they sued for peace agreeing to
give al a large slice of their operation
by March of 1929 Al Capone he was the
undisputed king of Chicago being
portrayed to the public as the ultimate
gangster yet at the same time he was
being read the riot act by his peers for
years the leaders of organized crime had
been holding annual meetings to discuss
matters of mutual concern now the matter
of mutual concern well it was what to do
with Al Capone al had attracted a
tremendous amount of unwanted attention
with the cynth Allen tines Day Massacre
he was bringing too much unwanted
attention as the king and as well the
time had come for him to be neutralized
the Commission decreed that Joseph a Leo
an old enemy of Capone would be put in
place in Chicago to keep owl in check
Capone would also have to cede his
gambling operations to the Commission
Capone was privately outraged that the
Commission was muzzling him in this way
but he was also smart enough to know
that if he protested he would quickly be
eliminated he decided to take the advice
of the Commission and lie low for a
while and what better way to safely lie
low than from inside a jail cell within
16 hours of coming out of the Commission
meeting Capone had been arrested for
carrying a concealed weapon
Capone entrusted his $50,000 diamonds
pinky ring to his attorney with
instructions to give it to his brother
Ralph who would become acting heads
intially returns he then began eight
month jail time when he emerged from his
prison cell in March of 1930 Capone
discovered that the climate had changed
he had been listed as public enemy
number one by the FBI the federal
government now considered him a menace
to society and was prepared to do
anything to put him behind bars for good
it was certain that Al was violating the
Volstead Act by selling liquor but they
were unable to prove it not even Eliot
Ness and his Untouchables were able to
stop Capone finally the FBI decided that
their best chance of putting the pone
away was to convict him of tax evasion
Capone was used to being cheered when he
attended public events but now that the
government was bringing income tax
evasion charges against him crowds they
started booing him what's worse his
formerly fail-proof methods of fixing
the outcomes of trials they were having
no effect al did manage to bribe several
jury members but on the day of the trial
the judge switched the jury panel from
that moment on four jurors were
sequestered
and they were out of Al's reach after
presenting a damning case which
highlighted a life of lavish spending
yet virtually no tax payments the
prosecution concluded by reminding the
jury that Capone was no Robin Hood he
spent wildly on himself and his cronies
doing nothing to help the poor and the
down-and-out the judge found him guilty
on three counts of tax evasion and on
October 24th of 1931 he was sentenced to
11 years in prison
this was the harshest sentence ever
handed down for tax evasion
Capone well he thought that now his
gangland associates would rally to his
aid but they just didn't get it
maybe his advancing syphilis had
something to do with it but the reality
was that had been artfully shunted aside
of the Atlantic City meeting in 1929 now
two years later his life was out in the
open for all to see and he had a felony
conviction to his name he was anathema
to his former gangland buddies make
Norton Capone spent most of his time in
an Atlanta prison and then spent the
last three years of his sentence of
Alcatraz by then his syphilis had
seriously eroded his mental faculties by
the time he died of cardiac arrest on
January the 25th 1947 doctors concluded
that he had the mind of a 12 year old
child and well that was all for Al
Capone
[Music]
now we'd love to know what you think of
this video please leave us a comment
below
and if you did like it why not subscribe
or share this video with a friend we're
going to be publishing two videos a week
just like this and also please do leave
a like if you liked it and as always
thanks for watching